« Génial. Il était temps. C'est pour quand ? »
(Rires)
Les hommes ont deux types de réactions.
Soit ils aiment l'idée,
soit ils me regardent avec circonspection
et se demandent ce que je réserve exactement à leurs testicules.
(Rires)
Alors pourquoi le monde a-t-il besoin d'une pilule masculine ?
Et si je vous disais que,
sur les six millions de grossesses annuelles aux États-Unis,
trois millions sont non désirées ?
C'est la moitié.
C'est un chiffre vraiment étonnant.
Ces trois millions de grossesses non désirées
représentent la grande majorité des plus d'un million d'avortements
réalisés, chaque année, aux États-Unis.
Heureusement, ces dernières années, le taux de grossesses non désirées a chuté
d'environ 10%.
Car davantage de femmes utilisent des modes de contraception
efficaces, durables et réversibles.
Mais on a encore beaucoup de chemin à faire.
Une approche devient enfin envisageable,
il s'agit de meilleures possibilités de contraception masculine.
Pensez-y.
Il y a plus d'une dizaine de méthodes contraceptives féminines :
la pilule, le patch, le stérilet, les injections, l'éponge, l'anneau, etc.
Pour les hommes, il y a les deux mêmes options
depuis plus de cent ans :
le préservatif et la vasectomie.
Même s'il n'existe que deux alternatives,
elles présentent toutes deux des inconvénients importants.
Les hommes représentent aujourd'hui 30% des utilisateurs de moyens contraceptifs :
10% des couples choisissent la vasectomie
et 20% utilisent des préservatifs.
Pourquoi 20% des couples utilisent les préservatifs pour la contraception
alors que leur taux d'échec annuel est de plus de 15% ?
Car beaucoup de femmes ne peuvent pas prendre sans risque
les modes de contraception disponibles, qui leur créent des caillots
ou elles n'en tolèrent pas les effets secondaires.
Si on estime qu'un mode de contraception masculine serait utile, il faut réfléchir
à la manière de le concevoir.
Il y a deux approches.
La première est d'essayer d'interférer
avec la manière dont le spermatozoïde nage vers l'ovule ou s'y accroche.
Cette approche s'avère très compliquée,
car il est difficile de traiter suffisamment le petit volume de sperme
pour que l'effet dure jusque dans l'appareil reproducteur féminin.
C'est pourquoi beaucoup plus de travaux portent sur la deuxième approche :
arrêter complétement la production de spermatozoïdes.
Cela représente aussi un défi.
Pourquoi ? Il s'avère que les hommes produisent beaucoup de spermatozoïdes.
(Rires)
L'homme produit mille spermatozoïdes par seconde
et, pour une contraception efficace,
il faut réduire la production de spermatozoïdes
à 1% de sa valeur normale.
La bonne nouvelle est que c'est possible,
presque.
En général, on utilise des hormones pour contenir la production de spermatozoïdes.
La testostérone et la progestérone, administrées ensemble,
inhibent les ordres donnés par le cerveau aux testicules pour produire du sperme.
Chez environ 90% des hommes,
la production de spermatozoïdes s'arrête après trois à quatre mois.
Malheureusement, 10% des hommes ne réagissent pas à ces dosages hormonaux,
pour des raisons encore incomprises.
Ces dernières années, mes collègues et moi
avons adopté une approche différente pour créer une contraception masculine,
une approche qui n'implique pas d'administrer des hormones.
On cherche concrètement à bloquer l'action de la vitamine A dans les testicules.
Pour quelle raison ? Depuis plus de 90 ans, on sait
que la vitamine A permet de produire du sperme.
Les animaux privés de vitamine A dans leur alimentation
cessent de produire des spermatozoïdes
et n'en recréent que lorsqu'on leur redonne de la vitamine A.
La vitamine A que l'on ingère
est transformée en acide rétinoïque, par une famille d'enzymes.
Une de ces enzymes ne se trouve que dans les testicules.
C'est cette enzyme que l'on essaie de bloquer.
Bloquer cette enzyme devrait priver les testicules d'acide rétinoïque,
arrêtant la production de spermatozoïdes,
sans affecter l'action de la vitamine A dans le reste du corps.
On teste cette approche sur des animaux
et on espère le faire bientôt sur l'homme.
Évidemment, les conséquences d'une telle contraception masculine
dépasseraient la biologie de la reproduction.
C'est intéressant d'imaginer quel en serait l'effet
sur les relations hommes-femmes.
Une opportunité fascinante,
pour l'homme, est de pouvoir contrôler peu à peu son statut contraceptif.
Au cours de ces dernières années,
deux groupes ont lancé des systèmes pour tester soi-même son sperme à la maison,
basés sur iPhone
et faciles à utiliser.
Un homme peut tester ses spermatozoïdes et partager le résultat avec sa partenaire.
Si le résultat est de zéro,
l'homme et sa partenaire sauront
qu'ils peuvent compter sur son mode de contraception à lui.
Un outil comme celui-ci, associé à la contraception masculine,
pourrait accroître le rôle des hommes dans la prévention des grossesses non désirées.
Les chercheurs travaillant sur la contraception masculine
cherchent à créer un meilleur avenir pour les couples.
Un avenir où la contraception ne sera plus juste « une affaire de femme »,
mais plutôt une décision commune au sein du couple.
Pourquoi a-t-on donc besoin d'une pilule masculine ?
Je crois que la pilule masculine
aidera à réduire les taux toujours élevés de grossesses non désirées, d'avortements,
et permettra aux hommes de participer, à égalité avec les femmes,
à la contraception.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)